I read that you aren't supposed to get IV vitamin C
impusions if you're taking Pectusol C. Can you explain?
Can I just not take the Pectusol C the day I get vitamin C?
So I don't recommend this. So I recommend that you take
that you don't. I do not recommend that you omit Pectusol when you're doing IV vitamin C.
Now you can certainly upon, you know, what other practitioners request,
not take the Pectusol C the day that you're doing the vitamin C IV,
but I have never actually told somebody to not take Pectusol C even the day that they're taking the
IV vitamin C. So I don't see the big cuts. I think some of the research that it's not going to work
as well if you're taking IV vitamin C, but it's just the day that you take IV vitamin C.
If you do take any vitamins, it's kind of a half length in your body and it's going to
discreet quickly, quickly. So,